Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Star Wars legends of
tomorrow video episode 9.
So much George Lucas stuff just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet, help
me, George Lucas, you're my only hope so excited
about legends of tomorrow this season so much
better than season 1 almost better than the
flash right now to, so there is a new round
of the reverse flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I have a
couple updates about the video schedule at
the end of this too first day of 3 day videos
DC TV rules from like Tuesday nights all the
way to Thursday mornings we'll see how long
my voice holds out.
Number 10 is just the basic premise of the
episode is George Lucas episode the reason
the writer said they chose this specifically
is because so many of them so many people
in Hollywood are inspired by George Lucas's
accomplishments by the movies that he's made.
So they wove that into the narrative where
the characters were so inspired by them that
they lost their powers because the timeline
to change any never made those movies so just
a great not to that but there was a lot of
deep mythology in the episode to, so number
nine.
We get back story on the Spear of destiny
and what happened to rip hunter at the end
of that first episode when he scattered them
all across time just to protect them.
So what happened is is he been hiding a shard
of the Spear of destiny.
Just a single shard not the entire staff itself
read the time matrix sort of reprogramming
his reality give a new personality basically
change them as a person from the ground up,
but if you watch Dr. who there's this character
called Clara that gets fractured all across
space time so there a bunch of different versions
of her existing in different time periods,
so that seems like what's happened to rip
hunter because we see them show up during
colonial times in this outfit here.
So number eight is they continue on their
treasure hunt like their goonies treasure
hunt to form the Spear of destiny will probably
meet different versions of rip hunter that
have different shards of the spirit itself,
but you do get that basic set up at the end
of the episode.
They have the medallion it is very Raiders
of the lost Ark for you have the staff with
the medallion on the top that's what they're
going for it was a very George Lucas type
episode so of course the McGuffin is one of
the McGuffin's from a George Lucas movie number
seven is this huge mind trip to a get super
meta-because citizen steel coins the term
Legion of doom taking inspiration from the
Hanna-Barbera cartoon which is the super friends
cartoon in real life that is talking about,
so when he says he pulled that from a cartoon
that means that the Justice league has existed
on television in Earth one's history of the
just blows your mind you like wait a minute.
Where did they get the inspiration for that
like do they create those fictional characters
is their version of Superman, Batman Aquaman
that actually exist on this earth so it just
meant to throw you for a loop.
There's always been hints that the Batman
characters exist in this universe that Superman
exist like the joke about Felicity's codename
Oracle already being taken.
So Oliver already knows about Barbara Gordon
and the fact that they have the Hall of Justice
on the flash now.
It just like another hanger that's near star
labs so you're making super friends on the
TV show Justice league style Hall of Justice
that's what it's called on the super friends
cartoon and citizen steel himself as a child
watch the cartoon makes me so happy that he
dropped that Easter egg you guys can let me
know what you think that means were those
characters in this universe number six.
You get the actual back story on the Spear
of destiny the spear that pierced the side
of Christ the centurions medallion the got
the blood on it.
That empowered it.
The difference between rewriting reality and
rewriting time using basic time travel.
So you rewrite reality it's permanent and
it doesn't cause any time quakes like you
would know anything was different the time
travel changes the time quakes that they explain
take a while to set it.
So they have time to fix them changing reality
very, very bad, but my number five was actually
Damien Darhk in Berlin throughout the entire
episode.
They were having more fun than anyone else
I totally love the way they wrote them.
They were way funnier than just casually breathing
down the sidewalk Merlin talking about all
the fun stuff that he wants to check out when
they're done all those people in 60s Hollywood
blows past the guard without missing a step
just him they were so good in this episode
the elevator music.
I will be so bummed out if these characters
aren't around in season three like it's much
better overall all the characters were better.
All of the writing the structure of the episodes
everything is better, but really it's the
villains that I think you're making the difference,
so number for the most hilarious thing about
the episode wasn't so much the George Lucas
stuff.
It was the way rip Hunter's play was making
fun of season one of legends of tomorrow.
The way he was saying, Vandal Savage was in
this scary enough villain is basically the
riders making fun of season one.
Making fun of themselves.
So it's a big eye winking from behind the
camera.
It was so good, but obviously you have all
the George Lucas stuff that was going on.
So there were a lot of specific, George Lucas
callouts, but number three all the George
Lucas Easter eggs, so there was so much stuff
happening around his character like a really
obvious stuff when Adam was like okay got
a get my Han Solo on now or they're talking
about Raiders of the lost Ark the actual movie
itself.
Howard the duck they totally burned that at
the end of the episode the fact that Rip gives
him the Spear of destiny, but he throws all
the props down the garbage chute into the
garbage chute fly boy.
I would ask you a question and your life depends
on it where is the city dump.
But just the way that they have to convince
George Lucas to go back to film school and
believe in himself.
I want to make movies so that they can get
their powers back but Vixen has probably one
of the best lines in the episode.
She gets the Princess Leia line she says,
George Lucas, you're our only hope number
two was the trash compactor pulled right out
of Star Wars then they get into the big trash
yard fight were the reverse flash shows up
always busy but always on time just making
you wonder where he was there teasing a little
bit of tension in the Legion of doom they're
going to start fighting with each other pretty
soon and you get the sense that the reverse
flash has been on some side mission that only
he knows about that they might address in
a future episode, but they'll probably also
address on the flash TV show because I'm expecting
him to go back before the end of the season.
Even if it's only for a little bit and they
tease that the black flash would be coming
on all the shows meaning that he will appear
on legends of tomorrow probably coming for
the reverse flash himself.
Typically, the black flash only goes after
others speedsters.
So it's not like he be going after Merlin
or Damien Darhk when he came back my number
one was rip hunter through the entire episode
the actor Arthur Darvill is so much better.
This season that he was in the first season.
I feel like them giving him a different personality
in the way that Tom Cavanagh is a different
character each season on the flash really
help them out because he is actually this
really well-trained really good dramatic actor,
but a lot of his season one stuff just felt
really bland really vanilla.
So this version of rip hunter is so much more
fun than season one rip hunter.
But I know I have an address that heatwave
stuff which was a big runner in the episode,
so he thinks that he's been hallucinating
Captain cold but really it just him, working
through his emotions as his subconscious.
Just speaking out to him, but it took him
a while to get there, so they go through all
these different steps trying to mess with
heatwave said scanning it like this can rip
Hunter's.
They even do brain surgery on that was one
of the funniest moments in the episode Grace
brings her to look like such as a great episode
I know a lot of you are like did you like
flash better did you like legends better,
which was the stronger episode, I still like
flash better but that's only because I like
the characters better the legends story was
a little more epic, just because of the stuff
they're dealing with the Spear of destiny
the flash episode was more about Wally West
fitting into the team and then figuring out
a plan for defeating savitar, so all the DC
shows sort of move at their own pace you have
to remember that legends of tomorrow only
has 17 episodes will the flash arrow Supergirl
they'll have 23 episodes, so their story tends
to get stretched out, just a little bit more,
so let me know what was your guys favorite
moment from the episode what you think that
the reverse flash was doing when he wasn't
helping out.
The Legion of doom.
Like he was off doing something else that
was super secret was can happen tonight just
an update on the schedule is I'll post my
arrow episode video next that I'll probably
do a legends of tomorrow Legion of doom trailer
video and then after that I'll try to figure
things out is going to be some more Star Wars
episode eight posting, but there supposed
to be a special Marvel announcement.
It might just be for kingdom heart so if there's
something really big I'll do a video for that
to congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner Brian Riley please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details to be a new round
in my arrow video that I'll post later tonight.
But new arrow coming later tonight black siren
get hype is can be awesome what you guys wait
for that to post click here for last night's
flash episode can click here for the flash
trailer for next week's episode thank you
so much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you in the next video!